many Apple users weren't happy with our
decision to give away u2's latest album
Songs of Innocence as an automatic
iTunes download u2 is a band I should
add that ranked number one in a poll
taken by senior Apple executives last
April and Gulf our retreat in Palm
Springs
so we thought this was a no-brainer but
apparently to today's youth giving away
a free album from one of the best bands
of all time
is like going to their house and taking
a gigantic crap on their doorstep so we
heard them loud and clear and quickly
launched an app that helped people
remove the new u2 album but we
understand some people are still unhappy
well I deleted the new u2 album but I
still remember hearing it you know so
it's almost like I still have it
and I hate it so I really want Apple to
do something about it I was humming
something and my roommate was like
what's that and I'm like holy crap I
think it's that new u2 song it still in
my head and she was like you have to
find a new apartment for these customers
we are going a step farther and are
introducing Apple's new erase you to
service which will not only remove all
memories of the latest Manitoulin but
will also remove any memory of the band
u2 whatsoever
[Music]
Plus after your procedure you will be
given an access code to automatically
download get this the latest album from
Irish rock legends you two guys are
really good if you're happy we're happy
but seriously a few it was a free album
get over it
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you